Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace
launching their new campaign.
Make your next move, make your next
move and set new goals for this year.
Lock down your next move idea with a
unique domain and create a website to
launch today by using offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
Make your next move with
Squarespace more@squarespace.com
this is radio lamb. I'm Jad
Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
And in this hour we've been
talking about, uh, aging mostly,
but now we're going to turn our attention
to the end of that aging process.
Well, you're talking about dying. Yes.
Maybe we've avoided that topic because
that's generally how people deal with
death, which is to avoid
it, to deny it. Yeah.
So this next piece is about actually
a different way of dealing with death,
I should say, before we begin it,
that it does contain some
graphic descriptions of the
normal bodily process of
aging.
But if you have someone in the room who
is squeamish or you don't think she'd
hear these things and it's nothing,
you know, terrible. It's just,
it's actually quite
nasty, nasty, nasty. Uh,
then maybe this is the time
to shoot them out of the room.
This piece was produced by Lou
old Koski. It's about one family,
three generations in introduce myself.
This is Jeremiah the youngest. Um,
Jeremiah Hagar. He's a filmmaker,
so I don't know if Isaiah is,
they are his dad. Isaiah is
a muralist. His grandfather,
I'm think Fran son of Asher's. They
go, I'm sure Zayic art is a health nut.
G Like, oh my shit.
This is a video of him that Jeremiah
shot of Astra doing his daily exercise
routine. He's in his nineties.
He's jumping on a trampoline
and counting each jump.
How old are you now? I'm 90 90.
You're in healthy man for 90 yeah.
[inaudible] 91 90. [inaudible] a great,
great grandfather named Dave [inaudible].
So you're going to live to 102,
I don't know. But the, maybe
at the age of 93, Asher began to decline
quickly. How do you deal with
a man dying in your house?
How do you deal with that? Well, you know,
my father starts taking photos of him.
One of my modes of understanding
was either drawing or photographing.
He was always taking pictures
of my grandfather. Just
see how dozens of slides.
Thousands.
That's how it went for awhile. Isaiah,
the dad would take care of his
dad and take some photos. Wow.
Grandson Jeremiah basically
looked the other way. Well,
I never really knew my grandfather, but
then Isaiah got an idea. I thought to
self challenge this young boy to this
duel who can take the most objective
photographs of a dying man. It wasn't,
we threw down and like I pulled my camera
out of my holster and he pulled his
camera out of his holster.
You know, it wasn't like that.
He was involved in my grandfather's
death and I wasn't. And so he said,
this is how I get involved. It's
my senior year in high school. Um,
and I was a bus boy in this restaurant
down the street and I loved it.
And I would bust tables till two or
three in the morning and then I would get
drunk with people after work and then I
would come back and I would take care of
my grandpa.
So I would lift him up and change his
sheets because otherwise his bedsore would
burn more when he had this horrible
bedsore you can see it in the photographs
and he would hit me while I lifted him
up and then I would photograph them cause
I would want to sit with him.
Cause when you want to calm him
down and the way you sit with them,
I mean my father was right. You have
the camera. I mean that's how you cope.
Otherwise you're sitting with
him and he's just looking at you.
During the contest,
Dad and son shared duties of taking care
of Grandpa and at night they'd sit at
the kitchen table and compare photos.
As soon as I took the first picture,
you knew I'm a better than my fathers
because my fathers were from far away and
there were snapshots and
mine were like specific.
Like I was fascinated with him dying.
I wanted to know what it looked like.
And this went on for about a
month. One during which time,
even Jeremiah's friends, all
of his friends got involved.
I had the wee hours of the night.
I would wake up and I would see that
they're surrounding my father or four or
five young people. Sure.
They were drinking beer and they were
joking around, but they were there.
They were there while he was there.
What I remember most was, uh,
you and your friends
changing his sheets and, uh,
lifting him and moving him around. So
like every island that it would be more.
Who else did it with you? John Lincoln.
He all became initiated into the
most problematic event in our lives.
It was an amazingly rare scene to see
these teenagers attending to death.
Well, this is a book of
photographs. So, uh, my father,
your grandfather's last week
of life in this very room.
So the contest was a month
long. Smart Guy. I am.
You're good.
You know how to even contest they
kept it con for one month kitchen.
Well, the feet look like they're, um,
they were out in the desert that
they'd been baked and cracked and dry,
dry, dry doubt. I mean, look at
them. They look like, I mean,
look at the nail. The nail is wild,
but I mean everything. It's like what?
I have these same legs.
Stop touching on photos.
Well, I can almost feel him like
feeling them. I feel you instead there.
That's bed sore. That's what happens.
Hello. It's awful, awful,
awful, awful, awful,
awful man who prided himself on
his health. Look what happened.
I just one describe that
it looks like riding me.
I mean they just opened wounds and
you're moving them around, moving around,
but still it was impossible. It's
crazy to look at the colors too.
Pink and then white, green and then
ground where it's, well the widest,
the muscle isn't, I took these photos
in color because I'm black and white.
You'd never get it. You know, you'd never
get how painful this must have been.
His anus was all red.
I mean like really red and you can see
the parts of it have broken and there's
just blood gushing out and it's dried.
I mean the blood is dried and
this is the last photo. Yeah,
you can see like the cognition
is gone on the mouth as a cape.
He's buried in his pillow.
He knew it was over.
It was just a matter of time. Now that's
it. That's the closest I got in dying.
He wanted to live forever.
Whoa.
The fix was in from the beginning.
The fix is that I was
supposed to add. Sure, sure.
How could it be any other way? I
don't know. I could have taken that.
I couldn't give it up.
You wanted me to win.
It was a subterfuge to get you to be with
your grandfather as much as possible.
I thought it was a fair Fairfax
and wasn't, ah, can you can.
They're asking you all already
couldn't take a good picture.
When a person is dying, it's very
important that they're surrounded.
Ooh.
They're surrounded by the light of life
and you don't go in to the place of
oblivion alone. You want me to be there?
I don't know.
At this point. I don't know. I'm
not, I'm not at that place yet. Well,
what does that mean with the camera?
I mean, just be with me. Yeah.
Demon with me. Be close to
me. Be Soft with me. Yeah,
I guess that's what it's
about. Really. Be Solid.
Whoa.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to Lou l Koski for that story
and to Isaiah and Jeremiah Zadar and now
we've come to the end of our hour. I
guess we should wrap [inaudible]. Um,
we should mention the website. Yes.
radiolab.org is the address and also if
you want to sign up for our podcast that
you do that, will you go to
radiolab.org or go to iTunes directly?
And if you want to send us an email,
Robert, if you want to send us an email,
you should really write us to our email
address, which you can never remember.
radiolab@wnyc.org is our
email address. I'm Jana boom,
Ron and I'm Robert Krulwich.
We'll see you later.
Hello. Did I wrong? Pinky? Wow.
[inaudible] Capello
[inaudible] production support by
Sara Pelligrino, Mark Phillips,
Scott Goldberg, Sam Lavin,
Dear Avior, he trust
Ryan Gummo and Jacob wine.
Virg special thanks to
Joshlynn Ford, Sam Dingman,
Leonard low-paid, Josh
Kane, this is Jeremiah Vega.
I want to thank you for listening.
Radiolab is supported by a grant from
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation.
Radiolab is produced by Wn Lysine,
New York public radio, and
distributed by NPR National Public.